this is the lady with the bump on her
face hit me and my face with a brick and
all these black men just once and they
don't give them
yeah that's mad
die would grab the Rock and it hit me in
my face and I want to give him my number
oh y'all just watched
literally a vet asked me for my daughter
I said no and he he picked up a brick in
front of so many men and was like
what are you gonna do and I told all
these men like yo why is this bad gotta
break all my face and he's he's holding
a brick
and all these [__] is watching then we
we get a little more context about what
kind of person this lady is because men
are not providers and protectors not
innately because they only protect what
they possess but we protect everybody
and we provide baby okay